if there was one outfit that defined
men's style in the 20th century
it would be the suit and tie and if
there was one outfitter who helped
pioneer that look
it would be brooks brothers but
workplace fashion has changed a lot
since the suit's heyday and analysts say
brooks brothers wasn't able to keep up
with modern men
who often wanted styles that were
cheaper and more functional
the tipping point came when the suit
maker was forced to shutter stores
during ongoing coronavirus lockdowns
and in july it filed for bankruptcy
brooks brothers is filing for bankruptcy
protection
it's planning to close about 50 of its
200 stores and that is the
the sort of decline in the suit people
are not wearing pinstripes to work in
the same way
here's how the retailer went from the
top of menswear to filing for bankruptcy
the brooks brothers brand identity is
built around its american roots
brooks brothers is the oldest american
clothier they along the way
have had a really outsized impact on
american men's fashion in particular
kind of defining
what men's style is in america and also
having a lot of different cultural touch
points
that impact started in 1818 when henry
sands brooks opened a men's clothing
store
in new york city he enlisted the help of
his sons
and the store was renamed brooks
brothers the retailer built its high
class reputation early
abraham lincoln wore a brooks brothers
overcoat seen here during his second
inauguration
and the company claims to have dressed
40 out of 45 presidents
heading into the 20th century the
company had a pioneering moment in 1896
when it introduced the button-down
collared shirt which would become a
staple of professional work attire
brooks brothers did a really good job of
basically being an innovator
and creating styles that you know were
something that men were going to want to
wear and put into their wardrobe and
especially put into the wardrobe
day in day out by the middle of the 20th
century the suit became standard uniform
for working professionals from madison
avenue ad
executives to middle america salesmen as
it grew
the retailer opened us factories and
began selling clothes to both men and
women
the big look for brooks was this kind of
natural shoulder
it was very easy wearing suit i touched
stone when we talk about this period is
always
the man in the gray flannel suit what
you would see in that movie
of a man on the train commuting into
work and everyone's wearing you know a
dark gray or dark blue
suit and they really helped kind of
hammer home that that was how men should
be dressing and what men should be
wearing
one of the retailers designs the
non-iron shirt
was a massive success but showed signs
men's fashion was becoming more
utilitarian
the business began to shift in 1988 when
the company was sold to british retailer
marx and spencer
markson spencer tries some things out
they try to update the stores
they try to update the shopping
experience they start to change up where
things are produced
at this point brooks's customer base is
pretty set in stone
they're they know what the brand offers
they rely on the brand for certain items
and they are for lack of a better term a
risk-averse consumer
but the 1980s are a time where fashion
is changing significantly for men
for the brooks brothers guy that was a
hard thing to stomach
throughout the 90s the retailer
struggled as trends towards casual
dressing emerged
that even reached the top of the
corporate world and in 2001
the company was sold again to another
foreign owner
this time to italian businessman claudio
del vecchio
he has big plans and a lot of analysts
and a lot of people that watch the
clothing space
have faith in it and they think that
maybe he can turn it around
he hires the american menswear designer
tom brown
to start brookshire's black fleece which
is this higher end
more niche line he also hires zach posen
who's an american women's wear designer
to become the head of design for
booktubers women's side what's amazing
about brooks brothers
is like i don't think there's anywhere
else in the market where you can find
such high quality make and fabrication
but all the while brooks brothers is
having difficulty
adapting and adjusting and getting a new
consumer in through the door
with the rise of silicon valley men's
fashion was skewing more casual
as tech ceos ditched the suit and tie
for vests
hoodies and flannels from 2016 to 2018
the market for suits was shrinking while
other apparel categories like sportswear
were growing so what we see is this real
push toward casualization
and toward not necessarily simplicity
but toward functionality a little bit
more
and away from the suit and
toward maybe the simple plaid shirt
that's a little bit more affordable
and so they lose this real interest
from customers and they really lose a
place in the market of being where men
go to for their clothing
in 2019 brooks brothers captured less
than one percent of sales for menswear
behind sportswear brands like nike under
armour and adidas
in 2019 with about 1 billion dollars in
revenue
and 244 stores in the us the retailer
began to look for a buyer
but coronavirus lockdowns in 2020 forced
the retailer to permanently close around
51 stores
and the shift to working from home
temporarily dried up the demand for
professional attire guys are just at the
point where they're
they just want to be comfortable and
when you're working from home you have
the ability to do that
we hear all the time now that men have
their quote unquote zoom
shirt that they will put on just before
they got on the video call and then take
off right after and just be sitting in
a tee at their desk brooks brothers
shifted production at its factories
towards mass making and sought
government funding through the cares act
but on july 8 2020 the company filed for
bankruptcy
in august a venture backed by apparel
licensing firm authentic brands
and mall owner simon property group
agreed to buy brooks brothers for 325
million dollars
potentially putting the company back
under american ownership for the first
time in over
30 years i have heard from a lot of
people that if they focus on quality
they might make it through that means
that their clothes are going to be way
more expensive than they have been
and yes that will appease a certain
customer but
that customer base willing to pay that
is much smaller
it remains to be seen how large the
demand for suits will be
after coronavirus and whether a new
owner can help brooks brothers win back
its core customers
or adapt to a more casual workplace